[Música]
muy buenos días me da mucho gusto estar
aquí creo que ya están adelantado un
poquito mi historia eso es lo que les
vengo a contar en este tiempo breve que
tenemos es una historia de amor mientras
escuchen mi historia lo que quiero es
que ustedes también vayan haciendo el
ejercicio de descubrir que tu propia
historia también es una historia de amor
a ver si lo logramos que ustedes también
descubran esa historia en sus propias
vidas yo también estuve en una prepa en
su momento todavía no existía el cumbres
que en tijuana estudie un instituto
méxico con los hermanos maristas y ese
de la mirada perdida que está ahí el
lado derecho soy yo aunque no aparezca y
me gusta esa foto precisamente por esa
mirada porque es algo que me gusta
cuando me dirijo sobre todo a jóvenes
animarles que siempre tengan los pies en
la tierra pero los ojos en el cielo
que disfrutes la vida tu presente lo que
tienes entre manos hoy pero que siempre
estés pensando hacia adelante que voy a
hacer con mi vida yo tuve la gracia la
suerte la gracia desde que era pequeño
de preguntarme qué voy a hacer con mi
vida quiero hacer cosas grandes quiero
hacer algo por los demás de hecho les
confieso que cuando tenía 12 años
tuve la inquietud posiblemente de que
dios me estaba llamando a ser hermano
marista estudiaba con los maristas y
quería hacer algo por los demás quería
ser feliz haciendo algo por los demás
rápidamente me di cuenta que no era por
ahí y papá no lo quiso después yo
tampoco pero fue como un primer aviso de
que algo vendría
pero si fue en esos años donde donde
empecé a preguntarme en serio qué voy a
hacer con mi vida y quiero hacer algo y
como les decía mirando hacia adelante
y recuerdo que en esa secundaria de aquí
de tijuana en esa prepa me di cuenta
pues que algún día iba a formar una
familia seguramente era lo que quería y
ya sabía que pues eso implicaba el
matrimonio pero quería saber con quién
quién será esa persona y desde ese
momento empecé una búsqueda quiero
encontrar ya esas personas como se
pueden imaginar no era fácil
a esos años 14 15 y 16 encontrar a la
persona con la que te vas a casar no es
nada fácil normalmente la gente no
piensa así de serio pero yo yo sí quería
ya tenía como ganas tenía como ansias
encontrar esa persona con la cual algún
día formar una familia pero también
estaba pensando en mi carrera
profesional y tuve la suerte de tener
muy buenos profesores que me ayudaron a
identificar mis cualidades me gustaba
mucho la química
me iba muy bien en las clases de química
y encontré con la asesoría de mis
profesores que podía dedicarme a eso
dedicarme a algo que me gusta pero no
solo porque me gusta sino para poder
hacer algo bueno con eso y ahí fue donde
decidí estudiar la carrera de ingeniero
químico y de sistemas en el tecnológico
de monterrey aquí estamos la graduación
de los 100 que nos graduamos ese año
aquí en la derecha
estoy yo sigo con la mirada perdida
mirando hacia adelante y me fui a
monterrey a estudiar la carrera de
ingeniero químico y de sistemas y ese
fue un tiempo como dice aquí de penas y
alegrías porque efectivamente se
empezaban a realizar esos planes se
empezaban a alcanzar esos objetivos pero
me empecé a dar cuenta que no era como
yo me lo imaginaba necesariamente en
todo que había que ser ajustes
continuamente que las cosas te las
imaginabas de una manera pero salían de
otra
y que así es la vida y que la vida te da
penas y alegrías y que todo es bueno
porque todo te ayuda a crecer porque
todavía todas te ayuda a formarte a
hacer esa persona que está llamado a
hacer penas y alegrías en los estudios
yo recuerdo que en la prepa me mala
costumbre o sea estudiar a última hora
por la noche el examen por la mañana
llegar y que te iba bien eso no funciona
en la universidad y me llevé mis sustos
por primera vez reprobé una materia en
la universidad y que no puede ser que
está pasando tenía que empezar a hacer
ajustes tenía que tener un equilibrio
entre lo que significa la diversión los
amigos pero las responsabilidades tenía
que aprender a administrar un dinero que
te daba en tus papás con mucho
sacrificio y que tal cansará para todo
el mes y no solamente en el campo
académico sino también penas y alegrías
en el campo afectivo yo seguía buscando
esa persona quien va a ser con quién y
había pues en ese mundo universitario
tantas opciones y era tan difícil decir
con quién será esta será esta tuve una
novia estuvimos un año y medio
si no si no llego a ser una relación la
verdad un poco tóxica para ella y para
mí y me di cuenta que no que no era tan
fácil pero que tenía que seguir buscando
y que la universidad exigía tanto que
quizás mejor lo dejo para después esa
búsqueda porque tenía que acabar primero
la carrera y así seguí adaptando mis
planes y mis ideales a la realidad pero
sin sacrificar los y dándome cuenta que
así es la vida y que a veces te
encontrabas injusticias dificultades
pero que forma parte de esa única
historia de amor hoy lo veo mejor pero
ya lo intuía desde entonces y ahí así
fue como en el año de 1992 terminé la
carrera ingeniero químico y de sistemas
y gracias también a que me fui
preparando esa misión esa visión que
siempre traté de tener de mirar más
adelante la tuve también en mi
universidad no quería solo terminar la
carrera que viene después que voy a ser
después y así pude aprovechar los dos
últimos años de la carrera para irme
especializando en aquella área en la que
quería trabajar
en la que además podría estar seguro de
que iba a aportar algo al mundo a la
sociedad tenía varias opciones pero dije
que aporta más que hace más bien y fue
cuando decidí aplicar mis estudios de
ingeniería química al área de la de la
ecología del control de la contaminación
de ayudar a la industria mexicana que
estaba entrando en el tratado de libre
comercio en aquel entonces a que pudiera
contaminar menos a que pudiera producir
mejor esos productos que necesitamos y
dije por ahí gracias a esa visión que
siempre con la ayuda de dios y de mis
formadores y de mi familia tuve pues
cuando me gradué tenía cuatro ofertas de
trabajo el día que me gradué elegí la
que más me ayudaba a conseguir ese
objetivo y empecé a trabajar y me fue
muy bien viajaba y ganaba más dinero del
que me imaginaba que iba a ganar recién
egresado
estados unidos-méxico empezaron a pedir
que diera conferencia de social cosas
que nunca me imaginé que iban a pasar y
curiosamente me di cuenta de una cosa
que eso no es suficiente que te vaya
bien en el trabajo que te vaya bien
económicamente si te da cierta
satisfacción pero había huecos en mi
corazón que no estaban llenos y me
hacían estar triste muy triste y me daba
cuenta que el trabajo que el dinero no
lo es todo incluso ni siquiera lo más
importante seguía buscando quién iba a
ser esa persona con la que iba a formar
esa familia y seguía también anhelando
tener una relación con dios como lo
había tenido cuando estuve aquí en
tijuana en un colegio católico y cerca
de mi familia y tenía esos huecos que
nos acababan de llenar hasta qué
1992 noviembre conocí a la que sería mi
esposa esa foto de arriba representa el
día que nos conocimos y fue la verdad
que un amor a primera vista como como de
película
nos encontrábamos muy a gusto el uno con
el otro siendo cada uno como es y me di
cuenta que una de las bases del amor es
crear a la otra persona como es y que
esa persona te quiera a ti como eres y
sobre eso sobre eso se construye
la relación del noviazgo creció y en ese
mismo tiempo noviembre del 92 también
fue cuando descubrí el movimiento al que
todavía pertenezco que es el reino
christi legionarios de cristo y también
fue llenando ese hueco que tenía de mi
relación con dios de llenarme
espiritualmente de llenarme
afectivamente y profesionalmente también
estaba ya todo encaminado o sea que se
empezaba a dar esa plenitud
sin saberlo necesitaba y que había
estado buscando desde siempre en esa
foto de abajo es abril del 93 y por qué
pongo esta foto porque inmediatamente de
este viaje a un six flags hoy en san
antonio
ella me descubrió un secreto
y pues obviamente si es un secreto yo no
lo sabía que tenía una enfermedad
incurable esa enfermedad se llama
fibrosis quística y ustedes se pueden
imaginar lo que en ese momento fue para
ella tener que descubrir que tenía una
enfermedad y que posiblemente
significaría pues que la relación iba a
tener que terminar según ella pero para
mí en ese momento fue la señal de que
por fin había encontrado a la persona
que estaba buscando no sé por qué no sé
cómo explicarlo no fue para nada difícil
cuando ella me lo dijo a decir ya está
la encontré porque me ayudó quizá eso el
verla que tenía defectos que tenía
debilidades y también físicas en su
enfermedad a decir la quiero más como es
y también quizás me dejaba a mí también
quererme más como soy con mis propios
defectos y debilidades y no se fue el
decir ya la encontré y desde ese momento
empezamos a
a conocernos más a querernos más hasta
que seis meses después de que empezamos
a ser novios la verdad que un poco
rápido pero también sentí que lo tenía
todo tenía un trabajo inmejorable
me estaban subiendo el sueldo me estaban
dando más responsabilidad dije qué
esperas si en contraste a lo mejor de tu
vida y seis meses después de que
empezamos a ser novios le di el anillo
de compromiso esa foto de la izquierda
recoge ese momento me dijo que sí y
empezamos a
organizar lo que sería nuestra boda para
el año siguiente para agosto del 94 y
todo fue como un sueño hecho realidad no
me lo podía creer el hombre más feliz
del mundo todo perfecto aparentemente
perfecto ese llegó el día de la boda y
yo esa esa mañana del 6 de agosto del 94
le dije al señor gracias lo tengo todo
no me lo puedo creer gracias cuánto te
debo no cuánto te dejo pero cambios de
planes inesperados se manifestaron
pronto inmediatamente después de la boda
en la luna de miel ella de una manera
misteriosa esa enfermedad que había
tenido siempre pero que había estado
controlada empezó a provocarle que fuera
a menos a menos a menos su salud se fue
complicando complicando complicando
tuvimos que interrumpir el viaje de
novios
ya no podía caminar la enfermedad que
tenía era un enfermedad que le afectaba
sobre todo los pulmones
tuvimos que venir los médicos no
entendían que estaba pasando no
respondía a los medicamentos que siempre
respondía y pues para no hacer muy larga
la historia el día 2 de septiembre del
94 maru murió ahí está la la
hernán el nicho en monterrey donde está
ella junto con sus abuelitos y una de
sus tías
y para mí ya se pueden imaginar el día
que ella murió fue no entiendo nada
pues no no que mi vida era una historia
de amor pues lo que me querías tanto
para que me dejas que me case no
entiendo era mi diálogo con ese dios en
el que creo y siempre he creído
pero misteriosamente me di cuenta en ese
momento también que yo solo no podía que
lo que estaba pasando yo no lo podía
cambiar y que en ese momento yo solo
tenía dos opciones o alejarme de ese
dios que siempre me había cuidado y me
había atraído hacia donde estoy porque
no lo entiendo aunque no lo entiendo
abandonarme en él porque lo necesito más
que nunca
y humilde y me abandoné en él
y le dije no sé lo que viene no sé lo
que está pasando pero lo que tú quieras
solo ayúdame esa misma noche del 2 de
septiembre a las 11 a las 11 de la noche
en la habitación de madre cuando por fin
encontré el silencio fue cuando el señor
me llamó al sacerdocio
tuve dos certezas esa noche no se los
puedo explicar es algo muy especial
la primera certeza que ya estaba en el
cielo que era feliz porque estaba con
dios pero que desde ahí me seguía
cuidando
y que él me llamaba mitad hacia el
sacerdote legionario de cristo eso fue
la noche del 2 de septiembre a la mañana
siguiente en la misa de cuerpo presente
con el féretro de ella yo sólo podía
pensar en lo que estaba viviendo en ese
momento estaba destrozado pero me seguía
abandonando en dios y en la humildad de
esa misa el sacerdote interrumpió la
homilía se dirigió a mí me dijo javier
te tengo que decir una cosa hoy maru se
casa con cristo pero hoy cristo se casa
contigo este sacerdote no me conocía no
sabía mi historia pero él sintió la
emoción de decirme eso y para mí fue la
confirmación en ese momento de que lo
que yo había experimentado la noche
anterior era verdad y en ese momento yo
salí de esa misa diciendo qué bonita
boda
qué bonita boda y la gente no sabía si
yo estaba recordando todavía la del 6 de
agosto llévense lo a que descanse el
pobre
y yo ya sabía que aquí el señor estaba
cambiando la historia muy diferente de
lo que yo me había imaginado pero seguía
siendo la misma y seguía siendo una
historia de amor y a mí sólo me tocaba
decir sí y dice que sí
el día 5 de septiembre hablé con mi
director espiritual le conté todo me
dijo adelante esto es de dios el día 7
de septiembre escribió una carta para
pedir el ingreso en la congregación de
los legionarios de cristo el día 12 de
septiembre me aceptaron el día 13 de
septiembre de renunciar a mi trabajo me
pidieron dos semanas para traspasar todo
el 30 de septiembre del 94 fue mi último
día del trabajo el 1 de octubre me
despedí
de mis papás aquí en tijuana el 4 volé a
monterrey el 5 me despedí de mis suegros
me llevaron al noviciado de los
legionarios de cristo y el 13 de octubre
del 94 40 días después de la muerte de
mi esposa recibida sotana ingrese
formalmente en la congregación a la que
todavía pertenezco desde entonces pues
diez años después me ordenaron sacerdote
en roma otro día especial tengo que
confesar que pasa tiempo a veces
requerimos tiempo para mirar hacia atrás
y pedirle al señor que te ayude a
reinterpretar tu historia pero cuanto
más miro para atrás más descubro y más
veo que sigue siendo esa única historia
de amor y desde entonces pues me he
dedicado a servir a los demás como
sacerdote pero con la certeza de que el
plan sigue siendo el mismo hacer algo
grande por los demás ser feliz amando
amando ser feliz pero que yo proponga
que yo ponga lo mejor de mi parte pero
que me siga adaptando todos los días de
mi vida al como la vida sale a tu
encuentro
se va manifestando el de arriba es el
mismo del de abajo no son dos historias
no hay una mala y una buena todo lo que
hay en mi vida incluso mis errores que
los eligió mis tropiezos que los he
tenido todo forma parte de una icónica
historia de amor y hasta el día de hoy
disfrutando de los amigos que tuve desde
la infancia de todas las cosas buenas de
esta vida pero con los ojos puestos en
lo que viene después yo te invito a ti
por lo tanto que tú también
si te ayuda en este día veas tu propia
historia y descubras que todo lo que hay
en tu vida todo lo que hay en ti todo lo
que eres y todo lo que venga forma parte
de una única historia de amor muchas
gracias por su tiempo
[Aplausos]
[Música]